direction la 10e circonscription des
yvelines philippe chevrier ex front
national est le candidat du front libéré
il souhaite prendre la place du député
sortant jean-frédéric poisson ses axes
de campagne
la limitation de l'immigration et la
réduction des dépenses publiques la
priorité c'est de sortir de l'euro c'est
évident parce que c'est une chose que de
redresser les comptes publics
c'en est une autre de résoudre le
chômage
alors mettons que ça nous coûte ici en
france 200 pour pâtes pour fabriquer un
produit 15 points de productivité de
moins ça veut dire que en allemagne on
peut le faire pour 85 bon pour les
français des centres de 100 à 85 étant
donné que la masse salariale
c'est à peu près 30% des coûts eh bien
il faut baisser la masse salariale de 30
à 40 % d'eau